six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's try our next caller
from the nine three seven area code
caller from nine three seven go ahead hi
David
this is Rachel from Indiana but this is
a Dayton Ohio area code okay
letting me know so I'm gonna kind of
come out here I was the one who posted
on the subreddit about whether or not we
really want to make Cavanaugh's
nomination and election issue huh and
first of all I want to say I really
appreciate your input and I very I
actually don't really disagree with you
that much okay I feel like what I was
trying to say was a little bit
misinterpreted what I was trying to say
is one I don't think that we really have
a chance to stop to like stop the
hearings or stop the vote from happening
until November right and number two like
in comparing it to the situation we were
in in 2016
the number one election issue that I
hear from like either never Trump
Republicans or reluctant Trump
Republicans is they want to control the
court mm-hmm I don't hear that coming
from the left
that's correct you're not hearing from
the left yeah I mean listen you are in a
sense that there's discussions of court
packing and the the urgency of
preventing Trump from doing any more
selections in that sense you're hearing
it but you're not hearing it as this
overarching desire to just be in control
of the courts yes exactly so coming from
a red state with a Democratic senator
who is at risk right now it's more
coming from that kind of fear of losing
losing that is where is where I'm coming
from so let me say I understand I think
I get what you're saying you're saying
that it's not that you don't care if
Cavanaugh is confirmed it's not that you
don't think opposing horribly
ideological right-wing Supreme Court
appointees is a bad idea
it's that you sim
we don't believe there's gonna be a way
to prevent him from becoming the next
Supreme Court justice and that there
would be sort of like political capital
spent on trying to prevent that and
making it a political issue that might
ultimately make it so that some
Democrats lose in November and then you
end up both with Democrats losing and
Kavanagh in the Supreme Court is that
sort of what you're saying yes and yes
exactly no that's exactly what I'm
saying the point of view yeah I do have
a follow-up questions though to that
okay what on what issues do you think we
do have the best chance to block the
nomination and still you know keep keep
the potential to get a majority in the
Senate uh I think the only you know at
this point I don't know that we can
block that you would need at this point
I think you would need some Republicans
to agree that because an election is
about to happen they want to hold
confirmation hearings after people have
had a chance to vote I don't think Pat
that there's any other way to force a
delay may be looking at Kavanagh's
record right like his inconsistency on
investigating presidents pointing out
that he's compromised in some way or
even like the baseball ticket debt that
he has yeah it could be something there
and I don't think there's gonna be too
much there I mean maybe it's just trying
to get a couple of Republicans to vote
against him but it just doesn't seem
like it's going to happen Rachel I mean
I think you're right that it's it's just
an inevitability and I hate that yeah I
mean I actually have a few ideas at
least for here
I wouldn't those posters to the
subreddit because they don't have
waiting and I even be having a
communication overlap so Rachel I
appreciate the phone call very very much
and I would love to see those ideas on
the subreddit